hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen ich poste das wünsche ich
habe vor einigen wochen ein video
gesehen wo die sich bestimmte produkte
bei mcdonald's gekauft haben und
bestimmte produkte beim börsengang also
die gleichen produkte die es beim girls
gibt auch bei burger king ich glaube ihr
wisst was ich meine freunde kauf beim
merchandising minister von de auf jeden
fall werden wir jetzt doppelt
fahndungsliste gemacht juli befindet
sich die firma carola genannte liste
vorbereitet mit zehn produkten diese
einerseits bei mcdonald's andererseits
allerdings auch genauso oder
beziehungsweise relativ wenig beim
burger king gibt wie beispielsweise
bamberger cheeseburger chicken wings
commerce et cetera pp auf jeden fall
fahren wir jetzt mcdonald's kaufen
produkte ein dann wären wir zum burger
king kaufen da die gleichen produkte ein
und dann sehen wir uns wieder bei mir zu
hause wenn ich blind foldete probiere
das was ist let's go
wer dieser mensch vor uns
er macht locker auf seinem pc
es ist ein langsames detlef in die
gesehene wir haben jetzt gerade hier bei
burger king
einige sachen geholt und jetzt fahren
wir zum mcdonald's
hallo hallo ich hätte gern ein
cheeseburger ein hamburger
ja
genau dann noch chicken mcnuggets 9a
bitte ja ein mexican classic lecker ein
double double cheeseburger eine pommes
bitte sie so noch ein hamburger royal ts
wo noch ein vanille milchshake ja danke
danke ich geb dir laden leben deswegen
muss der blume
und die menschen in peru sowie im grünen
wären wir nicht jetzt gerade bei
mcdonald's dann über die sachen ring
gekauft habt ihr wahrscheinlich gerade
gesehen hat jetzt mir und dann ja ich
hatte einfach mal machen
wir sind jetzt hier wieder bei der
wohnung angekommen wir haben hier unsere
ganzen macdonald speisen aufgetischt und
hier unsere ganzen bürger gegen
speichern
bitte versteht an der stelle dass wir
die maßnahmen wie weg dann ist die
sachen zubereitet oder bürgerkriegen
überhaupt nicht unterstützen
er befindet sich gar neben der kamera
hey du reagiert richtig schnell auf
jeden fall werde ich mir jetzt die augen
verbinden und juni wird sich dann eines
dieser produkte nehmen und wieder von
kleinen stückchen abschneiden wie das
auf diesen teller hier packen und ich
werde jetzt probieren und auch essen und
japan jetzt hans hofinger damit ich
sagen kann dass ich wirklich nicht sehr
bald sehen ja also ich finde ihn jetzt
nicht so gut entwickelt schwegler ist
ich lasse den zu essen das ist muss ich
jetzt eigentlich was ich probiere ich
erstmal cannes blind so schlecht essen
halten
das ist das nächste produkt werde die
hälfte abschneiden und ich hoffe es ist
so ich höre video ist die wilde relin
video
wenn sich das jetzt aus ihren augen
es ist ein bürger auf jeden fall
haben mcdonald's ist so besitzt der
kamera vor die gestern man irgendwann
vernünftigen burger gegessen das ist ja
einfach nicht richtig scheiße das stimmt
da weiß man wo es herkommt la la la la
la la la la ich darf nicht hinhören
gelegt dass ich höre was sie für einen
burger auspackt das hier unser nächstes
produkt okay und ich wtf und habe ich
der vorrat reicht ja will ist das
schwierig wenn ich mal wieder the
chicken mcnuggets und das ein statement
von mcdonald's mit zuschauer so ich bin
heftig fast und unisys schon wieder die
ganze anlage zum fressen sowie oder dann
gib mir mal das nächste gericht der
sterne koch hier hat das hier probieren
dadurch dass er das gerät hört sich noch
klassiker das ist jetzt das cluster
server das sieht eigentlich lecker aus
was er nicht wirklich heraus
der neue steps vor mir ich sehe ich
merke okay ist auf jeden fall ein großer
ich weiß jetzt mal war es sieht so
echtes mac noch richtig scheiße das ist
selbst mutter von working ja ja ja
boah da schmeckt so scheiße begann hier
besteht oder wollen sie alle sehen die
erraten was ich hier schon hören du
weißt darin aber sie hat das video von
etwa nicht gesehen hat nun den titel
gesehen
das ist eine vollständige idee ich habe
euch das video von dem warum verlinkt
aber ich habe bisher alles richtig
ja bin ich kraft
weiters es etwas zu trinken ach ja das
habe ich überhaupt keine ahnung wir
haben vorher ja eh die mcdonald sachen
stehen gehabt und wie die burger king
und mcdonald sachen man einfach von der
qualität her
krasser eingepackt kann man noch so
wirklich vom qualität reden aber ihr
wisst was meinen geschmack kann ich es
nicht jetzt genau sagen ob das bergwerk
dann ist aber an der verpackung will ich
sagen es schmeckt auch gut weil es hier
juli insgesamt folgen wollt das ist ihr
name könnte aber machen also checkt sie
gern mal raus und nehmen wir das hier
heute ich würde auch weniger
interessieren ob ihr habe mcdonald's
oder eher burton wird also schreibt mir
die kommentare mcdonald's wenn der
mcdonald's oder burger king wenn die air
berlin werden sollten ist fertig es
fertig ist schön dass wir heute gekocht
also es ist auf jeden fall wieder budget
war gar nicht nur lecker schmecken noch
entscheiden
ich hab das jahres erwarten sich
festigkeit als machen
[Musik]
die burger king kommission ahlen
vergrößern die burger king corp das
finde ich aber wirklich besser
weggekommen ist weil die bürger so
einfach wie gesagt das video von den
apps nicht gesehen aber wir haben halt
den ball
nehmen wir doch mal was zu trinken sie
zwar schon so gut es geht mir doch
vielleicht aber den man den effekt noch
okay das sind schickt mich mal wieder
gar billig aber hoffen ist die geborene
youtube welthunger britischen ja super
da jetzt etwas schwimmen da haben wir
wieder drauf packen so haben auf jeden
fall wieder einen burger am start
das fühle ich schon lang schicken das
haus der familie meine damen und herren
bei der augen tun ein bisschen wenig
habe jetzt hier viele verschiedene
produkte von bürgerkrieges probiert den
cheeseburger haben wir jetzt zum
beispiel und nicht gegenüber gestellt in
hamburg ots habe ich noch nicht gegessen
aber jetzt mittlerweile echt schlecht
wenn euch dieses video hier gefangen hat
das gerne mal einen like klar wenn euch
das video ultras gefallen hat was drauf
der 41 likes da wie bereits gesagt
schreibt sich gerne in die kommentare
der mcdonald's oder burger
in twitter so schreibt die kommentare
wenn ihr der bürger ging nicht typ
seit das könnte ich da noch sagen kopf
bei buchfreunde also ist jetzt
tatsächlich die im puppenhaus
wunderschönes weihnachtsgeschenk was ihr
ziel von bio das war's jetzt ihr vom
video hier können jetzt hier mal den
kanal abonnieren oder hier unten meinen
job ausschenken jetzt findet ihr zwei
andere videos und wenn ihr schon
abonnent seid könnt ihr auch die glocke
klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]